I want to jump to this story here from
the post-millennial oh my occupied
Democrats demands boycott of Spotify
after Joe Rogan says vote Republican
talk about a bunch of whiny little
babies Joe Rogan has opinion a quick
boycott the entire largest music
platform in the world luck with that
postmanuel says during a recent episode
of his podcast Rogan highlighted the
failures the Democratic party's handling
in the covet pandemic suggesting that
people should vote Republican instead it
drew Iyer from many on the left
obviously who went so so far as to call
their followers to boycott the popular
music and podcast streaming platform
Spotify I mean occupy Democrats they
post a bunch of fake news anywhere
they're kind of nuts they say if you
support a boycott of Spotify until they
drop Joe Rogan's podcast after he just
ignorantly urged Americans to vote
Republican as payback for businesses
closing down due to the pandemic
dangerous rhetoric as the GOP Embraces
full fascism oh my God please retweet
and follow us well you know Donald uh it
was Joe Biden who said semi-fascism they
had to one-up him I don't think they
know what the word means well I don't
think they care what the word means yeah
everything's upside down yeah everything
I mean they they you look look but I
pretty much this is going to go as well
as Neil Young's boycott of Spotify sure
sure I I propose this how about someone
out there makes a browser extension and
we select a bunch of keywords like far
right fascist semi-fascist whatever and
we replace it with bad thing
that's it so like bad thing person and
it'll be like you know business is
closing down due to bad thing or you
know uh GOP Embraces Embraces bad thing
just that that's all it means it doesn't
mean anything other than bad thing so we
get a browser extension it just changes
these phrases into the phrase bad thing
there we go that'd be the name of the
extension bad thing I like that actually
I would translate the left that's right
that's kind of that's really smart I
like it I want another one of your good
ideas and inaccuracy with occupy
Democrats here Rogan is not ignorant no
he's done enough research over the last
10 years I can I can safely say from a
distance the guy not a genius LOL
actually I think you are a genius Joe
but yeah I think he is honestly he's a
brilliant guy yeah um not ignorant he
knows what he's talking about this is
not a light decision that he's making or
talking about Joe's not a genius yeah
but he's been he's been taken he's been
smoking DMT and weed long enough and
psychedelics and uh NAD and so it's like
his mind has just ascended to a new
level so in the fourth dimensional State
he's kind of just a regular intelligence
but to all of us slowly
three-dimensional beings he's way out
there also if you watch that segment
he's saying vote Republican almost like
to bring balance back to this thing and
it was the Democrats that shut down
businesses they shut down our schools
they shut down our churches they left
you know the cathedrals to sin open I
left open the liquor stores they left
open the casinos
but they closed down the things yeah
they closed down the things that give us
community that help us you know learn
things they closed down libraries they
close down all this stuff and now we're
supposed to just be like oh that was
okay you did that for really good
reasons no they were garbage reasons we
all know they're garbage reasons you
have everybody walking it back you know
I mean you even had Kathy hokel stupid
governor of New York saying that it was
a mistake to close schools which so it
was obvious at the time and it's obvious
now they're saying it now because an
election's coming and they're scared
what I don't like about what Joe what
Joe said in this article but a lot of
people are saying vote Republican what I
don't like about that is the vague Bland
vote r on a ticket regardless of who it
is because idiot random dude that has
bad intentions can join the Republican
party and then get that vote you should
vote for the good candidate the right
candidate doesn't matter what party
they're in the thing a trans Satanist
Anarchist won the nomination for I think
sheriff or whatever by running France
satanistan who's up in New Hampshire
yeah it sounds like New Hampshire to
make a point to make a point being like
you would just vote for whatever's had
an r on it that's your fault people were
pissed they were like wait this person
won it's like you voted for them that's
like there was uh you guys probably
don't remember this but there was an
episode of Will and Grace where they
were trying to figure out who to vote
for and Grace was hosting a fundraiser
for the Jewish candidate and Will was
hosting a fundraiser for the gay
candidate they ended up getting into a
huge fight and whatever and then at the
end what's his name the other guy comes
in Jack Jack the best character on the
show he comes in he sees that they're
arguing and he's like why didn't you
just vote for the black guy and they're
like there's a black guy running and
they both run out to vote for the black
guy when was this this was whenever Will
and Grace was on what was that the 90s
it was hysterical it was like so perfect
bang on back when identity politics was
fun was amusing back in the 90s because
when they're also looking good before
comedy was terrorism right yeah really
that's 9 11 all over again I I keep
talking about pardons on this show from
time to time but it's like since 9 11
people went psychotic and we gotta like
just move on man because we are forming
a world government right now and if we
don't move on they're moving on without
us well let me let me look
to to put myself into The Fray let me
just point out like why this stuff
persists
The Daily Beast read this article I
mentioned earlier where they claim that
I'm I'm trying to lure people into my
right-wing world with rock music
this is the insanity that they're
telling people and I I don't want to you
know forgive the sort of self-promotive
you know promotion I guess that comes
out of this but my point is there are
people who read The Daily Beast as a
mainstream corporate publication and
this is the world they live in it is
literally insane they are in a psychotic
paranoid delusional bubble
they believe this stuff now I think The
Daily Beast is writing this because it's
basically you could create a a Daily
Beast article generator and click a
button and have it spit out a name in
some words Jack busovic far right you
know uh hoax or whatever and they'll
just randomly throw in random random
person's name random identifier random
thing they did and that's The Daily
Beast but when there are people who
believe this Insanity what happens to
their brains I had one guy
said he was mad at me for breaking
consensus reality bro you don't live in
consensus reality you live in the
crackpot reality of weird
algorithmically driven garbage articles
that make no sense but this is what
makes people lose their minds and the
reason why they hate Joe Rogan so much
is that Joe Rogan appeals to regular
people I think he may be a vaccine as it
were socially to stop people from being
of Contracting the mind the tip of the
needle so to speak you know you've
mentioned 911 a couple times I think
that's also coincident with when the
internet really took off which has
enabled division to be stoked but also
what's going on today
I go to universities and I hang out
sometimes on campus I've been to many
ivy league universities and I talk to
these students wearing my signs
they are teaching these kids now they're
training this generation
that it's not okay to have a different
opinion you can't just be okay with it
you have to be actively engaged in
trying to cancel the other opinion
anti-racism isn't just about
being Against Racism it's about actively
trying to cancel people who you disagree
with
and they're creating these social
justice Warriors this whole Young
Generation can't even have a
conversation
because words are violence to them and
it wasn't well look at in 2012 I think
it's tick tock I think that bite dance
and the CCP are really intentionally
driving this algorithm in the United
States trying to get people to hate each
other well I think tick-tocks I never
use tick tock once I don't think Twitter
is doing that Twitter is doing that but
what Tick Tock is doing is making sure
that anyone who opposes the cult can't
have a platform tons of people on the
right have been banned for literally no
reason I mean Tim cast IRL is banned
from Tick Tock we don't know why yeah
and they're from what I've been told
they're not it's a different algorithm
that Tick Tock uses in the United States
than what it uses in China the correct
Science and Technology to the top in
China whereas they push gender ideology
to the top in the U.S yep that's I mean
that's not not intention that's
definitely someone chose to do that but
this stuff was happening before Tick
Tock or any of these other things you
know there was this push to not educate
Scholars but to turn out activists so
it's a it's a completely different
way of
engaging in instruction right it used
like it used to be the way that you
engage at in a university is that you're
having a discussion you've all read the
material and any idea is open for
discussion it doesn't matter how crazy
it is it doesn't matter if you agree
with the idea or not come up with an
idea throw it out there let's talk about
the idea and now it has so much more to
do with you know forming a belief system
that then you can go and act as an
activist out in the world and get people
to sign on to your belief system that's
not what it used to be it I mean the
idea that a scholar is someone who has
to believe a certain set of things and
never question them that's not
scholarship that's that's cultish
Behavior speaking of activists I was in
San Francisco two months ago down by the
pier with my signs with a woman who came
up with me
and it was a weekday schools were in
session
there were about 80 elementary school
kids 10 and 11 years old
down there protesting
in favor of abortion and trans rights 10
and 11 year olds out on a school field
trip protesting on a school field trip
the school had them go out and do it
three different classes and they were
not they were not just protesting right
they were protesting for the eradication
of babies and for the sterilization of
teenagers I mean look as long as you
talk about anti-humanism if the
pro-america side if the freedom
libertarian side conservative side wins
on school choice then give it 20 to 40
years and the problem corrects itself
I think a lot of it like you were
mentioned earlier the internet how it
kind of coincided with 911 and I I think
what's internet video has been
weaponized I thought for sure back in
2006 like internet video is the future I
was right it's just been weaponized as
part of it and uh like for instance I
made a video when Barack Obama was
running for president 2007 I made a
video and said Barack you're gonna win
you're gonna serve two terms I was just
like let's manifest let's create this
and give it confidence so you're
responsible for all those kids and then
at YouTube one of the Steve Grove at
YouTube one of the administrators
featured the the article so basically
together we create a political
propaganda I didn't think of it at the
time I was just like I want Obama to win
it got 50 000 views I don't know how
many people voted for Obama as a result
but talk about Mass formation like the
the power of internet video that an
individual can Inspire the minds of
almost the entire world is
it's disconcerting thanks for checking
out this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there